[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors s'échapper
s'échapper se libérer cuire
s'enfuir du quotidien au contraire
retrouver les siens
ce petit voyage que je propose de faire
maintenant
un voyage depuis d'échappement
jusqu'à l'engagement
s'engager s'échapper mais de quel monde
ça c'est une question importante
effectivement de quel monde on va
s'échapper d'un monde qui est née au
moment de la modernité au moment de la
naissance de la modernité c'est un monde
qui est éminemment matériel
un monde qui est pyramidal y conte
particulièrement dans la prise de
décision décision descend les
informations remontent
un monde
fermé comment de les frontières existent
où les enjeux sont locaux un monde où le
régulateur l'état a son mot à dire un
monde peuplé essentiellement de gens
passifs
qui travaillent qu'ils consomment c'est
le monde de la société de consommation
qui a succédé la société industrielle
et le monde dans lequel on devrait aller
on y ait une certaine manière on en est
à superposer on est à la fois là et
ailleurs
c'est un monde qui est totalement
dématérialisé un monde
où le réseau a pris la place de la
pyramide un monde où les enjeux sont à
la fois locaux et globaux glauque au
monde où le régulateur n'a plus grand
chose à dire un monde voulait gafa
peuvent gagner des milliards être plus
riches que les états ne pas payer leurs
impôts mais un monde bonne nouvelle qui
peuplée de gens de plus en plus éduqués
de plus en plus outillé le plus en plus
sélectifs
le monde qu'on est censé quitter on le
doit à cet homme un monstre un génie qui
a fait de l'analyse l'alpha et l'oméga
de la maîtrise du monde
c'est une pensée qui est essentiellement
mécanique
c'est à dire qu'ils regardent le monde
comme une horloge et bien c'est une
pensée qui analytique résoudre un
problème c'est le découper en petits
problèmes qu'on peut découper en petits
problèmes et un homme tout seul peut
espérer résoudre les problèmes cette
manière là c'est une pensée qui divise
une pensée qui décomposent une pensée
séquentiel c'est une pensée linéaire
c'est pour ces motifs est en fête
et le monde dans lequel on leur a laissé
un mot qui appartient cet homme là enfin
qui appartient cet homme là un monde où
la pensée de cet homme là s'expriment ce
tome la sega morin edgar morin c'est la
pensée de la complexité c'est la pensée
de là c'est une pensée est ridicule et
c'est une pensée qui appose le
parallélisme des regards c'est une
pensée qui dit on ne peut pas comprendre
quelque chose en décomposant parce que
en le décomposant on le tue et en le
tuant on ne peut plus l'observer c'est
une pensée qui impose de parallélisme et
des regards c'est à dire la
collaboration c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle et donc
on abandonne la linéarité pour aller
vers la réalité et donc au lieu d'avoir
une approche mécanique on a une approche
organique
celles vivant
le monde que l'on quitte c'est un monde
qui ressemble étrangement à ça et à bien
des égards nous sommes encore là dedans
la ligne d'assemblage les temps modernes
de charlie chaplin vous voyez
le capitaine charles ont fait un geste
différent de celui qu à sa droite
différent de celui qui est à sa gauche
on ne sait pas ce qu'ils font eux mêmes
ne savent pas ce qu'ils font mais ils le
font il n'y a pas de problème il se
passe quelque chose à la sortie personne
ne sait quoi ça pourrait un frigidaire
une voiture ont fusé ces mêmes gestes
plus aucun sens dans ce qui était
produit on se retrouve mécanisée au même
titre que le reste et ont produit des
objets certainement mais sans aucun sens
une certaine manière tout a été conçu
comme ça toutes les sorties laisser
penser linéaire cartésienne et qui
transforme absolument tout en ligne
d'assemblage les écoles les usines les
villes les administrations nos vies
effectivement une ligne d'assemblage un
sofa dézoomer on ne peut pas savoir ce
que ça produit on ne sait pas quel rôle
on a et donc le monde en quelle on va
c'est un monde où en fait on va savoir
toujours ce à quoi on contribue et la
bonne métaphore pour ça c'est le chou
romanesco
le joug romanesco vous pouvez zoomer et
autant vous voulez à l'intérieur vous
verrez toujours le chou tout le temps le
jour c'est la même figure il apparaît
tout le temps
sempiternelle mans et donc si on regarde
le projet comme le chou romanesco comme
la métaphore du projet eh bien quelle
que soit la taille de la tâche sur
lesquels vous êtes en train de
travailler vous êtes le propriétaire du
projet vous êtes le propriétaire du ch
où vous prenez le jour
pour le projet
tout le monde les propriétaires du
projet tout le monde a la même
importance parce que tout le monde
contribue au projet quelle que soit sa
tâche en fait quel que soit son rôle
parce que les tâches ont disparu
alors s'échapper mais pour se confronter
à quoi
eh bien
ça dans la crise climatique la
réchauffement climatique voilà comment
blond américain qui finissent à
pratiquement toute l'humanité est
d'accord
la biodiversité menacée par tous
absolument partout du fait de l'activité
humaine
des injustices sociales oui on crée
beaucoup de valeur ont créé énormément
de valeur on la partage de moins en
moins les riches en plus en plus riches
les pauvres sont plus en plus pauvres
oui une classe moyenne c'est vrai
il n'empêche des égalités se creusent
partout quels que soient les systèmes
politiques
puis la colère des jeunes votre colère
une génération qui se tourne vers la
génération d'avant qui lui dit mais
qu'avez vous fait de ce que vous aviez
entre les mains
comment se fait-il qu'on soit aussi près
du mur avec toutes les richesses que
vous aviez à votre disposition
pas content les jeunesses à juste titre
et puis ça
ça change tout la moitié de l'humanité
qui réclament la place qui lui est due
le respect qui lui est dû d'être écouté
ça s'arrêtera jamais c'est heureux
et puis il est crise démocratique
j'aurais pu mais tous les autres images
le capitole ces anniversaires
partout dans le monde aujourd'hui
le gouffre se creuse entre les
gouvernants et gouvernés
la ligne d'assemblage
elle est aussi à l'oeuvre dans la
manière dont nous sommes gouvernés la
pyramide est toujours là et
particulièrement notre beau pays
on aime bien les pyramides sauf qu'à la
fin dans les pyramides
avec des morts
cette crise qui nous indique quoi nous
indique que le gouffre se creuse entre
les gouvernants des gouvernés et que les
gouvernants veulent plus de place
veulent être considérés peut être partie
prenante dans la prise de décision les
parties prenantes de ce qui concerne
leur vie il va bien falloir s'y mettre
mais aussi
et puis il ya ça
la numérisation de nos vies
on nous promet même qu'on va
vivre
dans cet univers-là sa promesse de meta
c'est ça le métavers
vous préoccupez pas du monde réel tout
va bien se passer dans le monde virtuel
sur une belle vie ici des vies de merde
là mais le métavers matou réseau
1.13 pourtant ça change absolument tout
ça et puis via sa
co vite maritine il se donnait au big
bag
ça éclaire de manière crue violente
cruelle nos d'insuffisance nos lâchetés
pause et 1 passe
mais aussi de solidarité mais aussi de
nouvelles opportunités
nous ne pouvons plus
considérer que nous allons pouvoir vivre
comme vision avant parce que nous
vivions comme des fous et que
probablement cette folie doit s'arrêter
s'échapper
commun
comment échapper
il ya trois questions importantes
première des questions c'est celle ci
gérer utiliser transformer des
ressources du monde de manière durable
et raisonnée c'est un impératif ne le
fait pas
aujourd'hui les gens qui font ça sont
des ingénieurs en général quand il vient
le front thilleman
plutôt mal pour l'instant
2e des points c'est qu'on ne veut pas
renoncer à avoir de belvis on ne va pas
renoncer à être entouré d'objets le
système d'objets service expériences qui
vont faire de nos vies des vies qui
valent la peine d'être vécue pour tous
et chacun
on va pas renoncer à ça mais par contre
on va faire en sorte en considération
les limites de la planète et puis le
troisième projet qui est plus important
c'est qu'il va faire faire ça
préparez motivé orchestré les meilleures
décisions possibles en fait tout se joue
ici tout se joue dans notre capacité à
prendre les bonnes décisions
tout le reste ce sont des conséquences
les objets les espaces du service des
systèmes l'utilisation de la matière va
contraindre nos prises de décision et le
président écision pour avoir l'impact
sur la matière et donc ces trois points
sont à ducey du moment lié
deuxième point comme pour les ingénieurs
deuxième point ingénieurs designers
manager marketeurs
troisième point ces jours là ils sortent
tous des écoles du pouvoir tous
xxl comme pina
totalement déconnecté du point 2
totalement déconnecté du point il nous
faut absolument réunir ce qu'il était
c'est pareil quitter la pensée
cartésienne
embrasser la pensée morale union est à
nouveau réunir ce qui a été séparée
pas pour ça là qu'une seule chose à
faire
c'est déjà le connaisse sa présentation
et donc c'est de passer de la matière à
la décision et pour ça donc qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
faut faire ça
il faut donner le pouvoir au design
véritablement
quelle arrogance c'est pas comme ça le
power design à quel titre pourquoi le
designer mais je vous parle pas des
designers je vous parle du design le
design est plus grand que les designers
alors on va faire un petit peu
d'étymologie pourquoi je peux me
permettre de dire une chose pareille
d'accord on va revenir un petit peu en
arrière va venir autant léonard desk
juste avant la modernité justement
dizaine y s'agir de dizaines et dizaines
yeux ça veut dire quoi en italien ça
veut dire deux choses ça veut dire ce à
dessein les admirables dessinée il
désigne le dessin
ça veut dire ça aussi claude et sa
moyenne
c'est-à-dire le roger en italien le
projet de loi s'est il disait n'y de la
leggia projet de loi
donc le design
c'est le dessin peut yens celle des
saints il ya un mot français qui disent
à l'e2c plan le plan c un dessin le plan
c'est un projet
et pourquoi
avant la modernité
desagneaux le dessin le dessin était
absolument mais c'est parce que autant d
honneur desk ce qu'ils aient les plans
des basilic et des douanes et des
cathédrales c'était ce qui les décors
rester les mêmes et pas de différence
entre les architectes et les ingénieurs
les artistes c'était les mêmes qu'est-ce
qu'ils utilisaient comme technique le
dessin
puis ce qui épate systèmes d'équations
c'est le dessin
donc pour revenir au temps léonard desk
en vieux français y avait 1 g après
dessins des singles
et ça a donné en traversant la manche
design
est un verbe français qui se souvient de
ce petit j'ai
quitté à la fin de dessin
ces verbes
et
quand on désigne quelque chose ce que je
veux là où je vais
je fais référence à sa au dessin yens au
dessin ian un design
la culture
du projet
donc le design qu'est ce que c'est ben
c'est pas un métier designer c'est un
métier c'est pas une discipline parce
que c'est la convergence de toutes les
disciplines c'est pour ça que le design
est plus grand que les designers tiers
c'est une culture du projet
avec quelquefois commission par la
mission de contribuer à créer les
conditions de l'expérience de vie
réussie
et ça se fait à plusieurs ça se fait en
réunissant le savoir ça c'est en
articulant nos ignorances ça se fait
collectivement
ça se fait pas sans designer c'est
impossible parce que cette culture il
apporte ce qu'ils induisent comme des
aimants la chambre force
ils sont très aimant les designers parce
qu'ils aiment les gens justement site
amour des gens c'est empathie pour les
gens il la partage avec en tant que
culture avec ceux qui sont dans le
projet
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une expérience de
vie réussie bah ça peut être ça
petit
dîner en amoureux dans un magnifique
petit restaurant français romain
waldau slovaque peu importe
mais tout a été conçu pour certains bien
la manière dont vous êtes accueilli la
décoration
les mobiliers l'art de la table le
design culinaire
tout la lumière on a fait le design de
ça on a fait en sorte que vous avec
votre dijk du soir
ça se passe bien
un moment privé public et privé à la
fois voilà intime
du plaisir une expérience de vie ça peut
être ça aussi je suis en train de mourir
ma phase terminale d'un cancer à
l'hôpital
expérience de vie c'est ce qui va se
finir mais ça
ça aussi ça ce design est ce que
moi en train de mourir là on me regarde
comme un numéro de sécurité sociale
comme une maladie ou comme une personne
humaine est ce qu'on est ce qu'on me
respecte dans l'environnement dans
lequel on m'a mis
orpea d'accord
s comme la state est ce qu on respecte
le médecin est ce qu'on a créé les
conditions pour qu'ils puissent faire ce
travail tellement dur d'accompagner des
gens dans leur fin de vie
est-ce qu'on veut respectueux et ce
qu'on respecte les infirmières qui sont
là est-ce qu'on respecte celle qui amène
à manger celle qu'ils nettoient celles
qui vont laver parti hier soir explique
le banc car discrète avec ma famille qui
vient me visiter mon père ma mère mes
enfants
la réponse est noire et général on n'a
pas fait ce travail là
on devrait absolument tout concevoir de
tenir ce que ça se passe bien pour tout
le monde tout le monde absolument tout
le monde
le design s'intéresse à sa juste avant
s'échapper
s'échapper pour devenir quoi
là pour devenir ça
c'est ça en fait il faut qu'on fasse
maintenant
redevenir des animaux politiques or
c'est étrange de dire qu'on fait
référence ces aristote qui par des
animaux politiques quand il parle
d'animaux politique et parle de nous des
êtres humains
les êtres humains sont les seuls mots
politiques sont les seuls animaux qui se
posent la question
de se donner des règles de vie
collective il a pas d'autres
et on a cessé d'être des animaux même
des animaux politiques quand avec la
révolution industrielle
la révolution industrielle qu'est ce qui
nous lie nous dit là si on se transforme
en technologie la technologie en process
les procès sont l'objet qu'objet honneur
il suffit que chacun soit sur la ligne
d'assemblage à sa place face qu'on lui
dit se pose pas de question c'est
automatique
vous achetez votre billet dans le train
du progrès vous monter dans le train et
on y va ça se bat bien se passer
et ça se passe pas bien il faut pour
mettre les mains sur le volant il faut
qu'on remette qu'on se remette à décider
nous-mêmes ou est-ce que nous il faut
que nous redevenions des animaux
politiques et bien sûr gouvernail
gouvernants et gouvernés
refaire de la politique au sens strict
du terme
parce qu'elle est en jambes c'est
maintenant qu'il faut agir
tout de suite pendant cinq ans pas de
raison pendant 15 ans
pour le vivant
pour les visions sur lesquels ceux
vivant n'a rien aucun sens sur les plus
personne pour savoir qu'il faut
absolument qu'on s'en occupe
et dans ce cas là on va se retrouver
exactement dans la situation dans
laquelle se retrouver l'enfant des
étoiles à la fin de 2001 odyssée de
l'espace
nouvelle ère pour l'humanité
c'est au fond des étoiles qui a compris
que la culture du design allait lui
permettre
en la partageant de s'occuper de cette
planète qui est à la fois surtout et
d'habitation sa destinée son dessin
la dernière phrase du roman de minutes
et d'espacé
il serait bien quoi faire moi je pense
que maintenant
que l'on se donne comme objectif de
devenir un animal politique à nouveau eh
bien oui nous serons bien quoi faire
faut qu'on s'occupe de nos dessins
viennent
faire du design
je vous invite à tous te faire avec nous
toutes les écoles doit se transformer en
école de dessin et yann le henné cela
aussi
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous